trying to draw some contact on Brees
Terrace behind the back dribble they
stood outside Thompson flock Duncan got
a piece of it that day comes out of the
control stick of hop situations so you
don't want to
turn back time what you don't want to do
is make
[Applause]
Duncan
Tim Duncan
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] off dance again hail Mary full of
grace
your prayers answer
how about that one
I've gotten satisfying
this is an absolute fair I mean he's
fading away over the top is like Timmy
shot in the playoffs live and he's wide
last year only Arron Afflalo had more
post points for a guard nice shovel from
joseph' and Duncan with the finish
so we have two excellent passing teams
here tonight come on you got an
advantage here for onto and Duncan
here's it down state awesome about great
recognition by Ginobili
great recognition by Ginobili 17 Jimmy
[Applause]
to Duncan
to Timmy in the paint just in time
found him and the Spurs with the final
foot
brings it off the screen comes up
shooting that's it ladies and gentlemen
you don't seem to fit me right there
gonna be a sprain vertebrae or seven
back there off the high post
Duncan's also a very good dancer gets it
back
he's the mismatch it goes right to it
Danny Green is night recover spies Timmy
excuse me foul and Tim a three point
five seven point lead they've done a
great job moving and sharing it and
eight blocks so and much of the energy
tonight Bonner the miss Leonard the
rebound Duncan the
opportunity game good time he goes to
Chris Paul as well my spin by Parker
Duncan
attempts to this lookout Tony Parker
look at all the white jerseys around him
he DeAndre Jordan even has been close
from the start biggest flea market of
six for San Antonio look at the pass
here click-click my friend look I think
that's what Gregg Popovich is making
sure we put on a roll here trying to get
up to that third spot beautiful play
Parker was a trouble gotta to dunk it it
counts and the foul again this is all on
Tony Parker every time he's been
attacking that paint area all the
attention and eyes have been on him the
biggest weight of the game for the
Clippers
[Applause]
- five ice bath
this spring and roll from splitter to
Tim Duncan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's offensive go tubing is Wachovia
by the got to make team play when they
put them build a guy right there
[Music]
[Applause]
and that man that the base nine needs to
rotate over only I think this Kevin Love
public knew right Chuck this is all
based off their ball there's a couple
rebounds but it's making an impact
[Music]
[Applause]
villager using the head fake boots a
[ __ ]
tipped it up into the air and it goes in
for San Antonio
that'll be seven kids bucket like this
what's the great defense here by hitting
boot to [ __ ] and if you will help on
the bucket they're just tips it up
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to the gate and ariza gives it up too
hard
on the drive it's luck
[Applause]
San Antonio Tim Duncan block by just
scoring no he did but they weren't gonna
call it's the end of the game he found
it
off the hands a Griffin intercepted by
Duncan out to Tony Parker over cattle
and the tip head by Kawhi Leonard
Paul maneuvers took him to the town
rejected by Duncan Duncan it was real
surprised about he talked about why
Leonard being the kia Defensive Player
of the Year here's the back to back
block 5 on the clock
Tim needs to get rid of it Oh tip
ducking finds winner but falls gonna
drop it right there to Tony Parker third
it's the floor and just unbelievable
where is there from number 21 how about
dinner to Sefolosha T conductances Thank
You Annie
[Applause]
not good news for the Spurs know I've
been at eighteen and for the second best
record in the league and they're showing
you why to Duncan gets the basket 39:31
and then Josh Smith who happens to be on
their team this year came out with an
incredible fourth-quarter string on one
duncan lays it up a napkin so far shoots
a ball with a nice rotation and a high
arc beyond the money and Timmy delivers
and Kauai hit by three Tim attacks it
orbs the contact and scores eight in
this quarter for Tim Duncan Green anima
used to be able to do that to Tony pages
challenge and block by Tim Duncan
there's Tim Duncan's nice pass long
baseline as soon as if banger brings it
out that fall gets be starter at the
other end by James doctored nice pass
inside
at home asked by Duncan this is why big
guys can be on the high post when you
spray at the fluoride o-ring
[Applause]
so glass Dedmon has been very active if
19 offensive rebounds at the AT&T Senate
in Duncan with the drive and the score
for Duncan how about hanging in the air
maybe that's not the appropriate word
with Timmy who the people we got to get
a few more out there so I think it's
gonna be more than one one unlucky
person that's gracious look here several
unlucky people
[Applause]
Oh Timmy spots almonds wide open for two
Tim Duncan
I'll say he just lemarcus just throws
blind Howard off
they're not just competitive there's
also an unselfishness see now we saw
bigots to see it all the time they saw
him come over and throw powder all over
me before the game Danny Green he's not
a stood around shot for Tim Duncan gives
him his first to the game Batum the
rebound timber Walker just 2 points in
the first quarter pressing the issue and
Tim Duncan swats that away leaps in his
sarcophagus for a couple nights in a
rebound off the fingertips of Randolph
collected by Ginobili down this late in
the second quarter you just don't want
to let this guy keep going downhill at
any time he's not stuck behind by Duncan
on Westbrook
mr. doctor yes
where you see the hockey assist you see
the regular assist in tremendous ball
movement I would almost equate chemistry
on the teams that I play with with the
number insist that we have what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content